les talibans ce n'est pas seulement des
hommes barbus vêtus du costume
traditionnel avec une vieille
kalachnikov en bandoulière c'est
également là badri 313 l'unité d'élite
des forces talibanes les effectifs se
trouve dans la quasi-totalité des 34
provinces d'afghanistan est partout dieu
merci ils accomplissent avec distinction
leurs devoirs ça qui est bien et
rapidement des missions qui leur sont
confiées la principale différence qui
saute aux yeux c'est la façon dont ils
sont habillés avec du matériel de pointe
empruntés aux troupes us lors de leur
départ d'afghanistan et auprès de
l'armée afghane
treille casque gilet pare-balles fusil
m16 mais aussi parfois lunettes à vision
nocturne un équipement à l'occidentale
pour ces soldats d'élite d'une
discipline à toute épreuve l'unité badri
313 qui tire son nom de la première
bataille victorieuse des arabes
musulmans est devenu le symbole d'un
savoir faire militaire inédit pour les
talibans le personnel militaire de
l'unité badri à une formation
professionnelle et comme l'histoire l'a
montré ils sont prêts à accomplir toutes
les tâches qui leur sont assignées nous
voulons accomplir des tâches similaires
à celles par exemple des forces
aériennes ou des troupes aéroportées de
telles unités doit être créée en
afghanistan
la mission principale de ce bataillon
indien s'est assuré la sécurité de
l'aéroport mais pas seulement il peut
également se déplacer dans le centre
ville de kaboul établir des checkpoints
des barrages pour contrôler les
véhicules en quelques minutes la
démonstration les fêtes et les véhicules
et conducteurs commence à être fouillés
par les soldats de la batterie 313 c'est
sur un checkpoint comme celui ci dans le
centre de kaboul qu'il ya trois semaines
une patrouille a été visé à la grenade
résultat une fusillade qui a fait
plusieurs morts et blessés
l'objectif principal de ce groupe de
soldats d'élite et de mettre au pas la
menace du groupe terroriste état
islamique en afghanistan et d'après leur
chef c'est dimanche ce fait
il a affronté d'âge de manière très
organisée il a obtenu des victoires et a
désorganisé son commandement désormais
des cheveux ne représente pas un seul
groupe soudé il n'a en outre plus de
commandement unique et si à certains
endroits une certaine menace de la part
de neige persistent la batterie et
d'autres formations militaires de
l'émirat islamique sont parfaitement
prête à faire face à cette menace vous
le voyez chaque jour nous organisons et
menons des opérations spéciales et
bientôt vous serez témoin de
l'élimination complète de cette menace
de quoi faire oublier que l'unité
d'élite avant la prise de pouvoir des
talibans s'étaient surtout signalés par
des attaques sanglantes et des attentats
violents outre leur combat contre les
terroristes de l'état islamique leur
mission est dorénavant de garantir le
calme et la sécurité à travers le